hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
and i've decided to create a few months
ago
my youtube channel the reasons behind is
that i want to pass the knowledge and i
want to show you guys everything i see
at work
all the different tools and techniques
that i use as a pro trader to make money
on the markets
and most importantly guys i want to
explain to you how to use it yourself
and you're gonna see that it's actually
not that complicated if you follow what
i'm saying
so today i want to make an update on gme
let's get into it
[Music]
on the daily timeframe very quickly what
we can see guys so this was the bloody
day i did my last video
here the volume was very low then we
have this plus 50
very strong rebound with associated
volume that are much higher
and now we are having this consolidation
just above the damaged sloping channel
and that i told you about guys
that i said that this is what we're
looking for we got it in two days
i didn't expect that to arrive that soon
we already have it and the volumes
associated just
above the strength line are still bigger
than the ones that we had on the bearish
day
guys this is the first information that
for me is very bullish
let's go on the hourly time frame and
i'm going to show you guys what happened
here
that is very interesting so i did my
video here and you can
go guys check it yourself i was saying
that the most likely scenario
is that we go to this downward sloping
trendline that i got by connecting the
two recent highs that i have here and
here
where you have a reaction here as well
and look guys what happened
so this trend line acted as resistance
perfectly
we arrived here bam very bullish we got
rejected
we go higher we break it we consolidate
we retested it and now i think there's
going to be a bit
more consolidation this is perfect all
right this is the typical situation that
you want to see before
getting in if you guys watched my video
before maybe some of you
bought the 170 175 level it's a very
nice trade
please guys use the stop loss if you
trade real money this is what portrayals
are doing
here your stop loss can be just below
this downward sloping trend line
what we expect right now guys is
actually something like this
when you have this kind of bearish
momentum that is shifting
to become bullish there is a lot of
damage that has been created on that day
and before this damage to be repaired we
just need some time once again maybe
we're gonna have a very bullish monday
and we're gonna go to 300 or something
like this right away that's possible
but if we see something like this
price action just you know consolidating
around this trend line
don't panic guys this is very typical as
well
and this is a good level to actually buy
more if you see the price action coming
here
so right now i turned very bullish on
the short term obviously
i see in terms of wave development very
quickly so here we have a one
i'm gonna do one more video we explain
everything this was not my campaign
before it is my counting now we need to
adapt guys all right
when we see something that is changing
so this is the one
we have the two here the two is finished
now we're doing three
four and five so we are having something
like this
so one two three four and five all right
and the fifth wave is probably going to
go to 800. once again i'm going to do
more video where i explain
exactly guys why 800 and why accounting
is like this
just here keep in mind that we are in
the third wave this is the wave you
don't want to miss
it's just started and it's behaving in a
beautiful way
very quickly guys let me show you why i
think a gamma squeeze is likely to
happen
i took open interest on yahoo finance
and i completed it
i'm gonna do a video where explain
exactly how to do it yourself so this is
the strike
so 100 200 so gme is around this level
right now
usually you have the maximum number of
options so the concentration is usually
maximum
around the money so 200 here we see
that we have a lot of option at 400 500
300
and guys look how many options we have
at 100 and this is for the short
maturities
so this is very explosive if you convert
it in terms of national
there are 2.5 billion us dollars sitting
at the 800 strike
so this is going to create a lot of uh
bullish momentum on the upside basically
uh market makers the hedge funds that
are left short those call options
will have no other choice than buying a
lot of gamestop to edge the position
or they're gonna create a shorter bigger
short interest that would ultimately
squeeze so in both cases this is going
to create a lot of
bullish momentum in the market this is
why i'm so bullish and of course i'm
bullish because this price action when
you look at it
with a step back is very bullish and we
are just developing in waves as we
always do
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys